This is FRESH AIR I'm Terry Gross. My guest Adam McKay is best known for
writing and directing the comedies Anchorman and Talladega Nights.
He's a former Saturday Night Live head writer and co-founded the comedy Web site
Funny or Die. He wrote and directed the new film The Big Short based on
Michael Lewis's nonfiction bestseller about the collapse of the housing and credit
bubble in two thousand and eight which led to the collapse of the global
economy the film's main characters played by Steve Carrell Ryan Gosling
and Christian Bale predict the collapse realizing what most Wall Street players
and top American financial leaders have failed to either see or
acknowledge that the bubble is based on bad loans for mortgages that the homeowners
will never be able to pay off. Here's a clip featuring Christian Bale as Michael Bari
a hedge fund founder and manager who's convinced that the securities of
bundled mortgages are going to lose their value. So he shorts them he bets against
them. The people invested in this fund already thought he was odd listening to
speed metal wearing T. shirts to the office and going
barefoot in this scene two of the investors in his hedge fund come to his office to
tell him his strategy is crazy.
I want. We have no confidence in your ability to identify
macro economic trends.
I flew here to tell me how why every and any one can see that there is a real
estate problem.
Actually no one can see a bubble. That's what makes it a bubble. That's dumb
always Marjorie's mortgage fraud quintupled since two thousand
average take home pay is flat but home prices are soaring That means the homes
are debt not
ask Mike burry a guy who gets his haircut at Supercuts and doesn't
wear shoes knows more than Alan Greenspan and
Hank Paulson talked to my priest as he
does. OK Adam McKay Welcome back to FRESH AIR
I have to tell you if you had come to me in there's no reason why you would have done that but if
you come to me and said. Should I make this movie trying to explain the economic collapse of two
thousand and eight and trying to and trying to explain all the financial instruments that caused
it like.
C.D.O. was. Which stands for I never remember what it stands
for collateral to realize that at obligation Yeah if you came to me and said Should I make
a movie like that. I'd say no don't do it
because I try so
hard in like two thousand and eight and two thousand and nine to
like having interviews that explain what was going on and we had on great explainers and they
would do a great job and it was still always confusing because this stuff is
just intended to be confusing. I
think so why did you think you could actually make sense of it and
make it an entertaining comedy even.
Well you know the book I was lucky in the sense that we had a fantastic book
by Michael Lewis and what he did was he did a very smart thing
he linked these amazing characters these real people that saw
the collapse coming before anyone
else with the vital information of the collapse. So their
emotional arcs are tied to this information. So I was done with the book I had
a pretty good view of what happened it wasn't totally
comprehensive but most importantly I was very emotionally engaged in these
characters story and the world to how deep he goes in the Wall Street. I'd
never you know had that feeling of being so intimate with that world. So
I knew right away the fact that they were so attached to the information in the characters that
you could do
it and then the next step I did was I just asked a lot of questions of a lot
of experts and read a lot of
books and my father. Annele kind of analysis was it's really not that
hard and that there's a lot of effort made on the part of the
big banks and the ratings agencies and in some of the financial
media to make it so complicated that people can't really
react to it but when I got to the essence of what really happened it really wasn't that tricky.
So had you lost money in the two thousand and eight down
or known a lot of people who did.
I did lose money I mean my story is hardly worth bringing out the violin
for
because you know we were fairly well diversified and protected but I had a close
family member who lost their home. I had lots of friends who lost their jobs.
It was more of a rippling kind of thing and then even with the Web site run with Will Ferrell Funny
or Die we had to
downsize we noticed movie studios in town started making fewer movies
that put people out of work. So the effects were you know far reaching.
And then I just found it really interesting that before I read this book and started doing research I
really didn't fully know what it caused it I knew there was a housing bubble I knew there was
some negligence and that's all I really knew
and I just thought that was crazy that we have this twenty four hour a day
news machine churning in this country and that somehow I didn't know the mechanics of
how this would
happen. So I have to ask had you invested a lot in the market would you
think of yourself as an investor and had you ever shorted anything because the whole concept of shorting
is essential to understanding how this whole game was played.
I have not shorted anything to this day although we keep joking now the people that work on the
movie whenever we go to like a restaurant and we get bad service we go we got to short this
place. But shorting it no I you know one of
the worst things you can do is to know a little bit about something and think you know a
lot so I am a lucky and I have to have a really good. Financial Advisor and I
still play it very conservatively. I've almost shorted a couple companies
but thank God I didn't one of them I was like I'm going to short them and then since I had that
thought they've gone up twenty percent
so don't listen to me for stock advice.
So if you had to make like a one or two minute pitch about what this movie is
about how would you describe it.
I would say it's about a group of outsiders and
weirdos and but at the same time brilliant people that saw
what no one else could see billions of people did not see which was that the world economy was going
to collapse and the question is why did they see it when no one else saw
it and how would you explain how that Milton was connected to the housing
bubble. I actually practiced this online oh that
family I practice with my wife and then eventually it got down to my ten year
old daughter Pearl from the
landlord and I got a really good friends
are funny and sketch the landlord. Yeah.
Exactly exactly and at first she was like that stop this is boring and then eventually it's like
Oh I think I see what you mean. So all it is is that at one point
in the late seventies a guy thought hey mortgages are boring. You don't really make a lot of money off
of them
but if you package thousands of them together and bundle them into one
bond a mortgage bar
and you can then sell them and with those returns you can make a lot more money
and because there are so many mortgages in it it's
safe. So they started doing this and they started making billions and billions of
dollars and banking started growing it grew four times the size it was in the seventy's
to where it is now.
But what happened was they ran out of good mortgages to put in these bonds because there's only so many people that can buy
homes so they started filling them with crappy mortgages they call them subprime when they're
really risky. So all the sudden these safe mortgage bonds that everyone goes oh
they're completely safe. Were filled with crap and no one noticed or
cared because everyone was making so much
money and then off of that they started making other types of bonds that were even riskier and
riskier and riskier and eventually those risky loans started defaulting and
that was it was like a domino just went down and it spread to foreign banks at that
point
and really literally brought down the world economy for like there was a day
in America where the paper markets froze which means there was no short term lending
between hospitals can't get medicine which means municipalities can't get fluoride for
their water and then they did the bell out of
course. Bravo that was good. That was pretty good
press right. I very much respect as very good and your
main characters like in the Michael Lewis book The Big Short are the people who figured
out that a lot of the mortgages that were bundled into these
securities weren't any good that they were going to be defaults on these
mortgages and so that the characters in your story. The characters
in the nonfiction book that they're based
on bet against these mortgages. And then when the
mortgages defaulted they made a lot of money on these bets that they mean.
Yeah these were guys that it really started with Christian Bale's character Dr Michael Berry I sort of
call him the oracle and it's really amazing what he did he basically
never left his
office and he sat in his office listening to heavy
metal and he read these mortgage bonds which are fill. There are so complicated
they're filled with thousands of mortgages and he went on line by line and he read a bunch of
the
bonds and walked out of the room saying this is a house of cards. So he was the one
who really sought way before anyone
else and then yes he shorted the housing barns
and then corrals character caught wind of it. Gosling's character of the two young
guys Jamie and Charlie played by Finn with John with Jerry. With Brad Pitt.
These were guys that
believed in the market they believe that when there's a bad investment. You're supposed to have a counter investment and that's
how the market stabilizes so they were doing the right thing and this really they were doing
what the market is supposed to do
but there's a terrifying moment in the movie where they realize they're alone on the
other side of this bet. And that the whole market's been compromised and the world
economy could go down.
So what they thought was a good sound investment in them doing their job
turned out they looked basically into the abyss and to this day when you talk
to these guys they're still furious they're still shocked they still can't believe that no one
was prosecuted and most of all they're
disillusioned and they're also very wealthy.
They are but it's it's funny I mean part of the movie is you know so much of our
culture keep score by money but I didn't see any of these guys
tap dancing around it's not like they're driving around in uber yachts and wearing like seven
thousand dollar suits I
mean the primary emotion you get from them is disillusionment and
anger. So you've managed in the Big sure to tell the
story of some of the main characters in the financial meltdown of
two thousand and eight in in a comedy in a very kind of
lively film and when you sat down and ask
yourself how do I do
this how do I take this kind of complicated Wall Street story that a lot of
people don't understand and make it understandable and also make it
entertaining like where did you like how did you start to wrap your head around
a method for doing
that I always viewed the movie as to move east the first
half is a little bit like a card counting movie where like the MIT
kids figure out how to count the cards at a blackjack
table and they're beating the evil casino. So there's a ton of energy to the front of
the movie you're really rooting for the. Guys it's kind of fun. It's fun to see the banks roll their
eyes at them and you know the guys are right.
Also some of the characters are very funny like even though they're being played very
seriously in a grounded way corrals character Mark bomb and his whole
team when you meet the real people they're very funny guys and they joke around and give each other a hard
time
so the first half of the movie does have that kind of energy and there are some laughs and it's and
it has like a motion to it that's really
great and then the second half I always viewed is where it becomes the
tragedy you think these guys of war in the village about the tsunami. They're up in the
hills and then they realize the tsunami is ten times bigger than the Hill they're standing
on so someone referred to the movie as a
traumatic tragedy a comedy which I think that is kind
of accurate Yeah it doesn't really
fit cleanly in any kind of genre box which is also what drew me to the story.
So you have some kind of ways for popular personalities. Not that I
necessarily familiar with all of them like actress Margot Robbie and
chef Anthony Bourdain and actress and singer Selena
Gomez explained some of the more contract complicated things in there just like
cutaways where like Anthony Bourdain in the kitchen and
Margot Robbie is in a bubble
bath. How did you come up with the idea to do cutaways like that and.
To find like the comedy a comic way for them to explain it.
You know it came about from really the what I think once again is the central question of the movie which is
why did these people see it and we didn't when the numbers were so obvious if you looked at him.
So one of the answers we started talking about was just this kind of White Noise Pop culture that
America has a lot of I mean the rest of the world has it
too so we started talking about the idea of like we want to represent that pop culture
in the movie we don't just want the movie to be in office. As with Wall Street guys talking we want
to see what America is
thinking and then offer that thought I have the idea of like what would happen if
pop culture actually gave us usable
information like what would happen if Kim Carr
dashin every time she was on camera explain the live or rate scandal.
You know what would happen if any time you're watching a red carpet for an award show and everyone
comes down in their gowns. You know each person you know talks about climate
change statistics and rapid change that's happening.
And so that's kind of where it came from and it felt satirical It felt funny
it felt like it had energy and at the same time it was a great way to get this
information across in a simple understandable way.
So I imagine you
making this movie and shopping it to two different sets of people as you wrote
it giving it one first like to the experts who actually understand
really well what's what happened on Wall Street getting their approval and then giving
it to people who didn't follow what happened carefully and seeing if they
comprehend what you've written is that is that what you did.
That's exactly what we did yeah it was a very interesting tug of war because we had Adam
Davidson was the consultant on the movie was an N.P.R. guy. You know he started
Planet Money
and and he has it been so great piece of Alex Blumberg called the big pool of money
for This American Life life addict. Explain one facet of the
whole meltdown of two thousand and eight.
I agree I actually think it's one of the better pieces about the meltdown if anyone has a
chance definitely listen to it it helped me a lot. So we had Adam Davidson was really
rigorous thinker he's a University of Chicago guy and then obviously I was reading a
lot and doing my own research and then we had the real people that we would talk to as
well so somewhere in between that pocket and then on the other side. I have
to communicate with a regular audience and we had some people in focus groups at Mitla. They don't
even know what a stock is or how stock works
so there were little things that would happen like when Steve
corrals says sell everything at one point in the
movie you actually wouldn't say that you would say on wind our position
or it's time to call in our shorts there's another way you would phrase it so
the experts said you would not say sell everything and I said yeah but an audience won't
understand that unwind my position what does that mean.
So it became this kind of horse trading game where what it was a key story
points. I would say well can he see it would it be terrible for him to
say so everything and they would finally confessed. No it's not crazy there are some guys that would say that so I
go OK they're going to keep
that. So. One of the lines in The Big Short
is that I'm paraphrasing here that Wall Street went from the
golf club to the strip club. You know from these you know this image of these
like you know boring guys
who like little men's club or the golf club to like you
know rip roaring out of control. You
know strip club kind of stuff so did you come up with that line with that phrase golf club to the
strip club.
Yeah actually gets country club to the strip club but you're correct entries up. OK Right.
Yeah I read a number that just shocked me which was that banking was
six percent of our G.D.P. our nation's G.D.P. in the seventy's and now it's twenty four percent.
So it literally grew four times the size of what it used to
be and I would talk to people about like when I was a kid I would watch like The
Beverly Hillbillies and Mr Drysdale the banker on there was like a lackey he was like
a toady and now a days that would not be the depiction of
a banker the banker would be the guy in charge and the oil guy would be chasing him
around
and so there was this massive shift that happened in the late seventy's and a
lot of it came about from.
These new types of bombs that they created they call them you know securitizations derivatives there's
a lot of different names for him but basically they're new kinds of
bonds and it just completely changed banking to the point where those types
of sales became way more than secure way more than
securities way more than
stocks and the amount of profits they were making just you know quadrupled.
And with that came a lot of lobbying power and that was when in the eighty's was in
the banks really said like hey let's hit Washington D.C. And let's start giving out some
checks which as we know is what led to the deregulation that we saw in the
late eighty's in the ninety's under once again under a Republican president and a Democratic
president this is not a right wing left wing story
so that line was trying to kind of show that that it went from the Country Club to
the strip club it went from the psych safe almost accounting like job
to your rock
star and you know like another example of how the stock market changed. I remember now
with growing up in the national news was on it would always end with
them how Wall Street did that day in Libya and today the Dow Jones was up
a quarter of a point or was down a half a point as opposed to up three hundred or
down two hundred fifty
absolutely volatility has gone through the roof there's no question.
So occasionally in your story. Ryan Gosling who is.
With Deutsche Bank in the story has characters with Deutsche Bank and he's also kind of betting
against the bank but. He's also the narrator of the film
and occasionally he comes on as the narrator and
says OK that didn't really happen that way but sometimes he comes on of the narrator and he
says what you're about to see it really happened this way
why did you decide to have a narrator explain when something was really fictitious and
then reinforce the point where something seems so outrageous but was actually true.
You know our whole goal with this movie was that we wanted to pull the curtain back as far as
we could see inside this world and I really felt like you had to have this
conversation with the audience not the whole movie doing it but occasionally we had to
check in and just let the audience know we're doing the best we can to really show you
what
happened. And I was influenced by there's a Michael Winterbottom movie called twenty four Hour Party
People that I really love that did a lot of that and you know a little bit from my theater
background I'd seen it work as well so there would be certain scenes in the movie
that were just so unbelievable that they actually
happened that while corrals character was giving a speech about
how Bear Stearns was no good and everyone's going down and he's arguing
with the guys saying No Bear Stearns is fine in the middle of that speech Bear Stearns is
plummeting Wiley's giving this
speech and if you wrote that is fiction that would just be bad writing. I mean it's
so cartoonish and also the fact that corrals character's
company found out about the deal through a wrong number which is actually true. So
I wanted to make it clear that these haphazard relationships these kind of
accidental you know deals that came about were absolutely true and a lot of times
that's how the world works.
Some of the characters in your movie have real names like Christian Bale's character Michael Berry is
a real name but I think most of the major characters are fictionalized
version of the people they're based on and the names have been changed.
So how did you decide who was going to be based on a real person with their actual
name and who is going to be more of a composite or a fictionalized
version. Really they're all pretty much the real people it was just a matter
of some of them for privacy reasons didn't want their last name in there like Jamie and
Charlie who are image arrow in Fenwick rock Those are the real guys first names and same
with Pitt's character not their last ages. But not their last names they just did they.
Said please don't put my last name in the movie because then everyone knows one hundred percent it's
me the one guy who is really kind of a composite is Gosling's character I would
say he's a little bit influenced by the real guy but because he's dancing in and out
of the movie as a character and a narrator I think that's the character where you see more
liberties taken where
he's definitely not doing an impression of the real guy but you know a lot of
the actions the real guy did and he is doing and there's some elements of the real guy in there.
So let's talk about your casting Christian Bale plays Michael Barry who's a trader at a
hedge fund. I want you to describe his
character.
Brilliant and he's he's you know the one. The funny thing in Wall Street is a lot of these guys
will slag on each other kind of like slightly poke at each other and go He's not
that good he's not that good but the one guy. No one ever said a bad word about was
Dr Michael Barry like everyone
acknowledges that guy is a heavyweight genius
and without exaggeration his job before he started a hedge fund he was in
his residency as a neurosurgeon and he got
bored. Bored with neurosurgery
and instead went and started this hedge fund is an amazing guy and I spend some time with
him and he listens to speed metal. I mean I'm not talking like light heavy metal
he listens to hard heavy
metal and he is he's on the spectrum. So he's able to hyper
focus and he will sit in his office for sixteen straight hours reading
documents. He's a sweet sweet guy and
his experience through this whole thing was just really miserable. I mean when he was
certain that he was right in the markets didn't change he got very physically
ill and almost had his lower intestine half of his lower intestine
removed and then the second that he sold his position or unwound his position. Instantly the
pains went away
so Christian spent a lot of time with them they. An entire day together just sitting in
a room talking and Christians very method so Dr Perry gave
Christian his real close and see in the movie that he tends to wear this one T. shirt and shorts
a lot that he actually wore during the period
and Christian learned how to play speed metal drums
and so it was an amazing process to work I mean we all know Christian Bale's one of the
great living actors and to really just see him become this person was was kind of
jaw dropping.
So let's talk about the character Steve chorale plays and when you describe the
character he plays a character. Mark
bomb who's based on a real guy Steve
Eisman and very very strictly based on him actually is really doing
the character based on
him and Mark Bond's a fascinating character he really is
a crusader and he's really a guy who looks for corruption
he looks for the B.S. out there and he looks for companies that are
fluffing their numbers that aren't
legit and he relishes you know shorting them or putting sell orders on
them and he had a long history of busting these bogus
subprime companies back in like the late ninety's early two thousand
and he had this team of people that are played beautifully by Jeremy
Strong Hamish Linkletter and rave
Spall and they all sort of had this distrust of the system their basic approach
was you have to prove to us that your company is legit. Otherwise we assume you're
not so when this trade came across corralled it's character Mark
bombs desk. He was more than ready for it when no one else
was and it quickly becomes a bit of an a Habs crusade for
him sort of the Ultimates corruption deal.
The ultimate sign that the and he's right all along the entire system is
rotten and he's the guy who sort of represents the audience a little bit his
outrage matches on. Ours and at a certain point a kind of a lot like a hobby. He loses
his mind a little bit and really it all becomes about this personal
crusade and you're really kind of worried for me is he going to wait too
long to sell is he going to self-destruct
and Corella just did an amazing job I mean he really transformed as I was put on
like twenty twenty five
pounds. Why did he need to do that why did he think he needed to do that. You
know there's there's a quality to the real guy. The real guy is not a bad looking guy
but he's a little bit heavier his clothes don't always fit him well I wanted Steve to be a
little bit sloppy. I didn't want him to be Steve's decent looking guys usually
in good
shape and these guys are all the guys with the you know the lousy clothes
the bad haircuts the guys who can't make eye contact so I needed Steve to kind
of just be a little off balance and a little uncomfortable and God
bless Steve he did it and
then the real guy's very larger than life guy really good guy but definitely larger than life
and and Steve found a way to really play him in this grounded way that still
had vulnerability to it yet right as anger and I really I
really think it's one of the best things Steve's ever done and he kind of blew everyone away on this
movie. So you cofounded Funny or Die and you do some videos for Funny or Die and it's
a it's a. It's a
comedy website that has a lot of different contributors and
you recently did something very funny called done although Trump has
with George Lopez like the Mexican Donald Trump would you describe
that video.
Yeah that was a piece I wrote with a Owen Burke who's the new creative head of Funny or
Die actually interesting lady whose dad was the created Nightline was
like a tiny and it is well yeah kind of interesting and now a son runs Funny or Die.
So the premise was well I just started laughing with Alan about the idea of like well wait a minute
out of the Mexicans feel about you know all the drunk college students. Come down there and all the
criminals that escape and go hide in Mexico
so we came up with this guy then I'll do a trump as who's the know the equivalent
the Mexican equivalent of Donald Trump and he wants to build a wall to keep
the Americans out and he wants to get rid of Sammy Hagar is to kill.
And he wants to get rid of Senor frauds and he wants to get rid of these factories that don't pay the
workers any money and pollute the rivers and it was funny we were reading it as sort of
an absurdist sketch and about halfway through we realized like wait a minute this guy is some good
points. He also wants to build a wall separating America
from Mexico because the Mexican cartels exist only because Americans have
an insatiable appetite for cocaine. He
says America America's color should be red white and below.
I
think they go and wrote that line I love that line. Absolutely and by the
way kind of a valid point.
So it was it was amazing that thing caught fire I think it got like twenty twenty five
million views on Facebook and a couple million on our sites and it just.
Yeah it was very cool and we specifically had Mr Lopez do it in Spanish too which
I thought was very
cool. It's subtitled on Funny or Die.
I have a really funny other sketch I did but it's. In Mandarin do you think you
could play that sure what you're getting the do you really have a
mandarin sketch. Well
actually they translated the landlord at one point into about twenty different languages.
So there really is a mandarin subtitled landlord that's out there but no I have not
recently written a mandarin
sketch. How do you think your sense of humor has changed over the
years.
I definitely think through the years I probably started more in my teenage
early twenty's as
just a fan of absurdist comedy you know I grew up on money Python and Steve
Martin I define that as I've gotten older I've just taken more of an interest in a lot of things in
the world. So that that leaks into my comedy more but I still think at root I
love comedy that has a prank quality to it a comedy that messes with
audiences and appends expectations or you think it's one thing and it's another
thing I'll always love that like I'm forty seven years old and I swear if they
didn't have caller ID I would still be doing crank phone calls. Did you do painful phone calls as
a kid. Oh my God constantly. Oh yeah. What was your
thing.
But it was age fifteen through college we had one we would do in college
where we would just everyone was constantly getting pizza. You know in
the dorm room so you'd get a call and I'd be like hey it's you know whatever pizza place.
Tony's Pizza giving your pre call be in the lobby in two minutes with your pizza you take the elevator down you get your
pizza you pay the guy you go back
up so we would just sit around because they had a student guide and so it's people's names you would call and
go hey is this you know Ben Levitan the oh yeah you know it's your prick call your pizza's company
you know I don't order pizza.
Look I don't have time for you smart asses. You know just come get your pizza.
I'm telling you I don't order pizza and he's go like look I am so sick of you
spoiled kids messing around with me I'm down here with your pizza get and then Ben Eventually we talked him
into a fight and be like I'll fight you right now and then my friend and I would run
downstairs and go sit in the T.V..
And we watch these four or five jacked up guys come out of the elevator pacing back and
forth flexing their muscles ready for a fight heat.
Did that. Dozens of times and and we tell people that their you know they were having a hot
tub delivered to their dorm room
or we call him up and tell him that I was an exchange student that I met the boss because you could see in
that student guy they were a Spanish major It's like Oh I'm well I'm at the bus station I'm in
from Nicaragua. Like what are you talking about. You know I'm supposed to stay with you your Spanish
based and.
We were idiots. We were full. On idiots but oh my god would we laugh.
Did you ever feel the least bit of guilt for doing this.
No none whatsoever they were all why not why not because. Because the guys you
had to
know I mean I went to Penn State for one year and I transferred to Temple University and there's a lot of
guys at Penn
State who are very jacked up and like to think of themselves as like want
to be football players and frat guys and the idea that he's
stirring up a bunch of those guys to come down into the lobby ready to
fight in the hot tub one was harmless no one ever did anything with just calling in
the person big walk there's a hot tub and you. You know Same with the exchange student would all just kind of go away so we
weren't taking anyone's money we're putting anyone in danger is kind of giving them
a chaotic hard time which I think is good I think that's healthy on some
level so long as there's not serious emotional distress.
Now I know early in your career when you were at Second City
and should you I'm sorry to interrupt I'm going to totally interrupt you. Yes you really realize now I am
definitely going to crank phone call you at one
point it's going to happen. What are you going to
do but you going to I'm going to tell you what I'm going to do but I swear to you I
promise in the next six months you're getting a prank phone call you're going to forget to think
oh he's just kidding around you threatening me it is not a threat.
It's a playful warning if you see that we're going to talk afterwards.
OK All right OK it's common.
OK OK So one more question Has making the big short about
the financial collapse of two thousand and eight and Wall Street's role in
that has that changed your relationship with your stockbroker.
My financial adviser love the movie he really loved it.
I have a cousin who's in private equity is two and I had a little conversation with
him before I saw. You know this movie
is not targeting bankers banking is good we actually need
banking but banking that overreaches are banking that has corruption is not
good and can do a lot of destruction and right now banking just has way too much
power so we really went out of our way with the movie never to point the finger at any one
individual we
really believe it's a systemic issue so so far all the banking and finance people
in my life have really enjoyed the movie but who knows I could be talking to you
in two months from now and I'll have a black guy after someone's punched me so we'll
see I was thinking you could talk to your financial analyst or manager
or whatever their title is on a on a higher level than you ever could before.
Oh well actually that's funny I mean as far as talking to my
financial advisor. I have
annoyed the crap out of I have gone
and talked to these real people these geniuses and they've told me things and I go back to my guy
and I just go mad. You never going to believe it there's a you know there's a bubble in
this and we have to short. This and always it's the same thing he takes a two second pause and then
just relax.
God bless him he's got the patience of Job but and thank God he doesn't always listen to me.
And I'm a case in great to talk with you again thank you so much. And I wish you Happy Holidays and a wonderful two thousand
and sixteen.
Terry always a pleasure. Happy holidays to you as well and and much love to
my hometown of Philadelphia.
Ana McKay wrote and directed the new film The Big Short.